first time in a before I've been here
before actually my old manager sent me
on a writing trip cuz you guys have the
best writers in the world and so I got
here and he was gonna put me up in hotel
which was really nice and I got to the
hotel right after landing and I was
starving it was late at night maybe like
not too late 9 o'clock and I said is
there any food and they said oh you know
better than that no food after 8:00
Rachel knows like excuse me and I get to
the room and there's a workout ball and
a treadmill they're like now do your
exercise it was like a physical fitness
hotel he put me in the wrong hotel I was
like oh my god did you send me to lose
weight yeah I was kind of insulting yeah
it really really hurt my feelings I mean
I had a lot of like self-doubt at the
time so God maybe I need this hotel okay
but this was a riding trip as you say a
bit yeah so you you were here to work
with composers or yes songwriters and
producers I worked in London for a
little bit and then I worked in
Stockholm for about two weeks and the
album before this present album that I
have out was mainly composed of songs
written here really I mean you know
secretive when you're here like that
little tear as well and nobody knew you
know it's like a oh I know one would
have cared if I was there four years ago
no maybe I maybe wouldn't have cared
holster was there a specific moment in
your career where you realize that I
want to be an artist yeah a very
specific moment I was studying in
Trinidad which is in the Caribbean and I
was working at the diplomats office at
the time and I had studying wood I was
an international relations major I
didn't I wasn't an artist I didn't think
that I was good enough to go into music
yet so anyway I am working at the vet's
office and a friend of mine is in a band
in the local band and their backup
singer was sick and he was like oh gosh
we have a huge show we need a singer and
I'm like I'm a singer
he's like you'll do all right so we went
to the show and it was in front of
thousand people that was my first
concert with a band and it was like
lightning struck me and I just knew I
had to change the focus of my life and
that was what I was supposed to do
so it was like 80,000 people that was
the first time yes did you guys have
such a defining moment did you ever
I had one yeah what was that it's in the
studio just next door here which I my
mom loved this it was a very popular in
Sweden in those states was he loved her
or not and she really loved he loved
Lena Taylor she was a great group he
smells the whole stairs yes sorry and
she wanted me to be in the show and I
was very shy I was like six years old
something and she pushed me like from
the audience and she know that someone
should go they she took up some kids to
juice there's something with the big
story and they they put they put that
one in that one or that one and my mom
pushed me so hard because they didn't
point of me
so I fell down and came in like that and
that is my entrance as an artist
oh no more what about you better yeah I
think I had my first experience when as
an adventurer when I was in 2000 I
joined North Pole trip and I've always
been kind of a reckless person and
didn't knew exactly what I wanted to do
and at that moment when we reached North
Pole that first time then I decided
this is something I really enjoy doing
this of setting yourself goals and
trying to reach them so that was my you
know this anointing in North Pole trip I
mean before joining that you must be
sort of motivated yeah but you know it's
I thought that was a one channel or one
time chance and it didn't plan on so no
no I didn't so so before fight some
before the the the big breakthrough how
did you promote yourself um I was very
creative and very ballsy like in breed I
made up an email address for a booking
agent and I think her name was like
Rachel's great at Gmail just really
smart
and I wrote clubs and I was like ah
they're just new artists she's
incredible she's played huge rooms I
have never played anywhere other than
like the local bar and I booked twice
all with these small little comedy clubs
the coffee shops around America and they
weren't all that glamorous but it was
pretty amazing but it worked it worked
yeah yeah what was her email was a WWE
internet probably what would you say
from that time I mean from that tour
from this is many years I mean you're in
your mid-thirties so it's you're in a
way a late bloomer when it comes to this
business what's your most vivid memory
from the early times I think there was a
jam that we had on Tuesday nights
you guys have the word jam here I just
like a hang a lot of the local musicians
and touring musicians would all go to
this one place called slain it was an
Irish pub on MacDougal Street in
Greenwich Village where I lived and it's
just really an amazing time of our lives
it was really special
those Tuesday nights would just be
packed and people would be standing on
the table singing along and we passed
the microphone around and everyone would
bring a new instrument and the bar would
just be alive I remember looking like no
matter how bad things were how broke I
was I would be looking so much looking
forward to the Tuesday nights you know
cuz I remember how much I loved what I
was doing you you say when you when you
talk about your fight song I read one
place that that it's it's really about
some experiences that were that were
actually hurting you at the time what
were those experiences well it wasn't
always you know enjoyable loving Tuesday
night hangs I was getting rejected a lot
I was putting myself out there a lot and
I'd get close to getting signed by a
label and then be turned down alright
get close to getting an opportunity and
it wouldn't work out and I think like
everyone pursuing a dream like if
there's something that you really truly
feel like you were put in this world to
do and you're not quite able to do it on
the level that you think you are
supposed to be doing it at it hurts and
it makes you question everything like
what else do I have to do I'm working so
hard and pouring everything I have into
this and it just wasn't working and I it
just made me question like what what do
I do next but you really need the the
self confidence yeah my confidence was
very shaken the song was about that my
publisher called me up and she said you
keep trying to write hips like you're
swinging for the fences and you're just
trying to write these big courses that
don't really mean much but you're not
telling your story you're not sharing
what you've gone through going and I
didn't want to talk about it and want to
it hurt I didn't want to go there but
then that day that course of fight song
came out as if I turn on a faucet and
I've just been waiting to pour out of me
and this song is I mean it's a Japanese
it's as it's sort of
Ansem it's a sort of song that that to
many has been helpful I understand
because if you if you take a look at the
Internet you can see that people are
really using this song yeah in difficult
situations do you do you hear about that
do you do you know who you are all the
time it's the my most favorite part of
what I do it's incredible there was a
woman named Christine luck and Baathists
before
fight song was on the radio or anything
it was released a year before I got
attention for it and a woman heard it
and she was fighting cancer she her
tumors had returned after 15 years in
remission
their niece emailed me and said my aunt
Christine sent out an email to all 150
of her friends and family saying I have
several months to live but I don't want
you to be sad I found this song and this
is how I'm feeling and she attached the
song so her niece sent this to me and my
producer and I read it and we were like
we have to do something we can't just
you know write back
so he went to where she lived across the
country and we got a film crew and we
found all of her friends and family and
we gathered them all all 170 at them I
think and they all learned fight song
and we surprised her with it it was the
most beautiful thing I've ever been a
part of Rachel thank you so much